okay now can we generalize this can we
see like what's happening here in
general terms so now what I want you to
do is um this is just our particular
example before let's generalize
generalizing multiplication that's what
we're trying to understand it
multiplication in what art form because
we already know how to multiply in um X
plus iy form it's just you know
arithmetic how do we do it here okay
well if I've got two complex numbers
okay two complex numbers any complex
numbers right they're going to have
different moduli and different arguments
I assume if they're different numbers
okay so let's call the moduli r1 and r2
okay now I could call the arguments via
one and theta two
but it's you're going to start getting
overwhelmed in subscripts okay so
instead I'm going to choose another name
for an angle pair of angles that you
guys are quite familiar with namely
alpha sorry not that one again alpha
four that's our first complex number and
what would you like to suggest for our
next one how about beta
okay so we've got lots to choose from
but I think this will get the 1/2 nature
of what's going on yeah if this these
are what z1 and z2 are right what
happens when we multiply happens when we
multiply now I'm going to take that X
plus iy approach I'm just gonna do the
arithmetic over right I know they look
messy but I'm just going to multiply the
first one all the way by the second one
okay now the first immediate thing you
see is what happens to the moduli you
just want to apply them just get r1 and
r2 just hanging out the front doing
their things no big deal okay what
happens in this messy stuff
all the trig functions okay now it looks
bad but if you stay with it it's gonna
come good watch right let's just do the
pair's first cos alpha we'll multiply it
by both the terms I get cos alpha cos B
oh then I guess I cos alpha sine beta
okay with that
by convention of putting my eyes so not
the front and I'm putting the angles I'm
making gangs the order of my trig
functions then I'll do my second pair
right so I've got I sine alpha cos you
know that's these two guys here and then
I'll get I sine alpha times I sine beta
that's I squared sine alpha sine beta
okay now I want you to get call back to
this morning and I said we're drawing
together lots of strands right what
strand of mathematics is screaming out
to you from this line this is trig
functions and in particular shape
expansions right have a look at the
parent let's remember this is going to
be a minus 1 right so which term is this
gonna pair up with in the first one cos
alpha cos be done effectively minus sine
alpha sine beta you see it there and
then in the middle here once you take
out your factor of Pi you've got cos
alpha sine beta sine alpha cos beta okay
so what are our let's reverse the
expansion's right I've got my R 1 R 2
sir what's cos alpha cos beta take away
sign off the soybean which treat
expansion is that that's causes it it
causes the one which has this the cos
cos side sign okay it's cos now don't
forget it's it's mine yeah good so close
it the moment you flips around the signs
so you've got alpha plus beta you don't
you okay right with that now the next
bit first I take out my factor of I and
then what trig expansion gives me the
red path it's fine isn't it
sine of alpha plus video okay now that's
really amazing it boils down so simple
what we got here if I multiply from
color if I multiply complex numbers Z 1
is n 2 in what are four things happen
through the moduli and things happen
through the arguments right I swear this
is just a cosmic coincidence of the
English language and words we've chosen
but when you multiply complex numbers
what do you do with the moduli what
multiply the moduli okay that's the
first thing you do right cuz look they
just come out the front and you don't
need to deal with them anymore right so
the modulus of a product is the product
of the moduli right that's kind of neat
okay what do we do with the argument
just Adam right we multiply the moduli
and you add the arguments no you there
me I love to try it like like square peg
into a round hole squeeze alliteration
into everything but I didn't have
anything to do with this okay this is
just the way it is now please please
please note okay this is not just some
random coincidence right we actually do
quite a bit of work to get there we had
to use some trig identities in here we
had to match up the real and imaginary
components but this beautiful result
pops out okay and now you can see why
this is an appropriate time to introduce
radians angles and rotation are built
into the fabric of complex numbers in a
way that they are not for real numbers
okay because real numbers are all in a
line
no wonder there are no angles happening
right they're all zero okay whereas here
you're interesting stuff happening okay
now can you see why why this happened
why did the one stay one what does think
one because of modulus all the way
around was one why is that
okay I I'm retaining around the same
circle because the modulus of what I am
multiplying by what's the modulus of I
it's one isn't it that's the mantra
that's how far away I am right so the
modulus is one so no wonder I keep on
staying the same distance around okay
but then what happens to the angles
right we go we had four zero PI on 2 pi
3 PI love truth I kept going and get 2
pi which is zero okay so you can see
this pattern happy okay